que l'italie plus de 18 mille neuf cent
l'europe reste l'épicentre de la
pandémie avec plus de 780 mille cas et
plus de soixante quatorze mille décès le
ce pagne l'espagne observe tout début de
régression avec 161 1900 cas et près de
16000 400 morts en italie
l'épidémie poursuit là aussi une très
lente régression avec plus de 147 1600
cas et près de 18000 800 décès en france
nous sommes confrontés à une épidémie
massive meurtrière qui a atteint vous le
savez un niveau inégalé qui aujourd'hui
a touché plus de 93 1790 cas confirmés
par test pcr soit 3114 de plus qu'hier
et depuis le début de l'épidémie plus de
60 7300 personnes ont dû être
hospitalisées ce soir avec les données
de 1187 établissements de santé nous
savons que 31 mille trois cent vingt
personnes sont hospitalisés pour une
infection qu'ovide 19 en 24 heures ce
sont quand même deux mille quarante
quatre nouvelles personnes nouveaux
malades qui sont entrés à l'hôpital
cela représente encore une hausse même
s'il ya beaucoup de sortie encore un
solde positif de 53 malades à prendre en
plus par rapport à la veille l'épidémie
reste donc toujours active 6883 patients
graves nécessitent des soins lourds en
réanimation en soins intensifs ou soins
continus 33 % de ces patients ont moins
de 60 ans 61% entre 60 et 80 ans et il y
a encore 99 pour personnes de moins de
30 ans qui sont hospitalisés en
réanimation au cours des dernières 24
heures ce sont 255 nouveaux patients
contre 431 hier qu'ils ont dû être admis
en réanimation c'est encore très
important le sol de la différence entre
les entrées les sorties qui représente
donc le nombre total de patients
à prendre en charge et pour le troisième
jour consécutif négatif de 121 patience
étaient 62 - hier ses 121 patients de
moins présent en réanimation aujourd'hui
c'est une nouvelle très légère
diminution des besoins de place et cette
éclaircie semble se confirmer et va
évidemment soulagé nos soignants en
particulier en réanimation
un très haut plateau épidémique semble
se dessiner mais je voulais dit
l'épidémie est active il ya beaucoup de
cas encore qu'ils arrivent à l'hôpital
nous devons absolument continuer à
rester vigilants mobilisés et prudent
dans les outre mer en relève 137
hospitalisations dont 42 en réanimation
au total depuis le début de l'épidémie
s'est fort heureusement 26 3 191 tonnes
qui sont sortis guéris de l'hôpital
c'est un chiffre qui continue à
progresser de jour en jour et auxquels
il faut ajouter les dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui ont guéri spontanément
en ville sans recours à l'hôpital
la surveillance syndromique en
population basée sur le recours aux
services d'urgences ou à sos médecins
montrent qu hier les services d'urgence
sont accueillis 2466 passage pour
suspicion de co vide à la suite de ce
passage aux urgences 41 % des patients
ont été hospitalisés et 3 % directement
transférée en réanimation
en ce qui concerne sos médecins on note
6 134 interventions hier pour suspicion
de kovy êtes un peu moins qu'au cours de
la journée de jeudi cela représente
désormais 12 % de l'activité totale de
sos médecins
nous surveillons de très près la
situation dans l'ensemble des
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
vous savez qui est un dispositif
spécifique de signalements qui est mis
en place depuis le 28 mars et qui
continue à monter en charge depuis le
début de l'épidémie donc depuis le 1er
mars
nous avons 35 1864 cas de co vide 11175
confirmés et 24 1689 possible dans près
de 5200 établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux
qui participe donc à cette déclaration à
cette remontée d'informations tous les
cas confirmés en france sont consolidés
dans le total national que je vous ai
donné de 93 1790 cas confirmés selon
santé publique france en ce qui concerne
la mortalité hospitalière 8900 43 décès
sont à déplorer depuis le 1er mars 81 %
de ces décès surviennent chez des
personnes de plus de 70 ans
on note 18 17 18 décès pardon en
outre-mer 10 en guadeloupe 5 en
martinique et 3 à mayotte
au cours des dernières 24 heures ce sont
donc 3 153 décès supplémentaires qui ont
été enregistrés à l'hôpital
nous déplorons par ailleurs 4889 décès
ses 290 de plus qu'hier qui sont
survenus en établissements sociaux et
médico sociaux depuis le début de
l'épidémie donc depuis le 1er mars
l'essentiel de ces décès est observé au
sein des ehpad 4779 décès et cent dix
ont été rapportés par des établissements
médico sociaux
si nous faisons l'addition des décès
survenus en milieu hospitalier et de
ceux survenus au sein des établissements
sociaux et médico-sociaux deux pays de
preuves 1er mars
nous déplorons donc 13 1830 de décès en
france en lien avec l'épidémie qu'ovide
et donc je redonne le chiffre des cas
confirmés par est par santé publique
france et des tests réalisés positif par
pcr il s'agit bien de 93 1790 cas
positifs soient 3114 de plus qui hier
je ne leur dirai jamais assez surtout au
cours de ce long week end ensoleillé
c'est en restant chez vous que vous
éviter des drames
sauvez des vies je sais que cela fait
désormais plusieurs semaines que nous
faisons passer ce message et que vous
subissez le confinement je le redis
encore une fois il ne faut pas relâcher
nos efforts collectifs et je
souhaiterais prendre quelques instants
ce soir pour rappeler pourquoi ces
mesures sont en place et pourquoi elles
sont plus importantes que jamais
comme vous le savez les mesures de
confinement les mesures barrières les
mesures de distanciation physique au
minimum d'un mètre et de distanciation
social en réduisant les contacts sont
mises en place dans notre pays comme de
deux comme dans de très nombreux autres
pays du monde tout simplement pour
réduire le nombre de contacts entre nous
empêcher donc la transmission du virus
d'une personne à une autre
on oublie parfois qu'elle réponde tout à
cet objectif simple cas c'est empêcher
les chaînes de transmission les chaînes
de contamination et donc freiner le plus
possible la progression de cette
épidémie
c'est pourquoi nous testons rapidement
en tout cas suspects nous isolons les
malades à l'hôpital ou à la maison
et pendant que collectivement nous
freinons la progression de l'épidémie
nous faisons en sorte que notre système
de santé que notre système de santé
hospitaliers puisse prendre en charge
tous les patients qui développent des
formes graves de la maladie
avec le doublement des capacités
nationales de réanimation rendue
possible par la déprogrammation précoce
de toutes les activités médicales et
chirurgicales non urgentes
le plan blanc déclenchée dans tous les
établissements de santé de france les
renforts massifs en volontaires en
soignant en médecins et les évacuations
sanitaires en très grand nombre
si 150 évacuations sanitaires de malades
de réanimation ce qui a été mis en place
par l'ensemble des services de l'état
est à ce titre exceptionnel
pendant que vous restez chez vous et
lutter contre la diffusion du virus
les personnels soignants des femmes et
des hommes au dévouement exemplaire ont
permis d'organiser le transfert de
plusieurs centaines de patients dans un
état grave depuis des zones très
fortement touchée depuis des hôpitaux
saturés par l'épidémie vers des zones
moins touchée vers des hôpitaux qui ont
permis un accueil dans d'excellentes
conditions
pendant que vous restez chez vous et
combattez cette maladie très contagieuse
les services hospitaliers et les
services de l'état ont organisé le
transfert de centaines de personnels
soignants volontaires qui viennent
renforcer les services de réanimation
qui ont tant besoin de bras
supplémentaires mais surtout du soutien
de leurs collègues pendant que vous
restez chez vous pour éviter que
l'épidémie ne se propage
nous organisons l'acheminement de
matériel de réanimation doublons nos
capacités d'accueil dans les services de
réanimation de 5000 à 10000 pendant que
vous restez chez vous et que vous
réaliser de magnifiques actions de
proximité de solidarité
nous faisons en sorte que la progression
de l'épidémie ne dépasse jamais la
capacité de notre système de soins à
accueillir et à soigner tous les malades
alors je voudrais remercier tous les
soignants les établissements de santé
publics ou privés
tous les volontaires toutes les femmes
et tous les hommes qui rendent cela
possible avec un mot particulier de
remerciement pour l'ensemble des
citoyens qu'ils restent chez eux
je vous remercie toutes et tous et vous
invite à continuer à vous protéger et à
protéger vos proches en particulier les
plus fragiles d'entre nous nous aider
nos aînés et à continuer à aider nos
personnels de santé à faire le
remarquable travail qu'ils accomplissent
jour après jour nuit après nuit heure
après heure
vous pouvez aussi vous applaudir pour
cela j'ai dit hier que nous avions
amorcé un trait au plateau si cela se
confirme c'est que nous aurons réussi
cette première étape tous ensemble cela
signifie que les mesures de confinement
produisent leurs premiers effets mais
cela reste un très haut plateau
nos services de réanimation prennent en
charge un nombre totalement exceptionnel
de patients
les admissions à l'hôpital reste très
nombreuses les médecins de ville les
médecins spécialistes sont inquiets de
la dégradation de l'état de santé de
leurs patients les plus fragiles et nous
déplorons nous déplorons malheureusement
de beaucoup trop nombreux décès nous
devons donc tout faire pour prendre en
charge au mieux les malades atteints du
goût vide mais aussi tous les malades
non atteintes du coc vide les infarctus
du myocarde les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux les pathologies chroniques des
compensées toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont besoin maintenant
aujourd'hui de soins spécialisés en
ville ou à l'hôpital
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est
beaucoup trop tôt et absolument pas
raisonnable de faire des pronostics sur
l'avenir nous le savons tous cette crise
est inédite
cette crise est grave et elle va durer
restons pleinement mobilisés et
solidaires
je vous remercie de question pour le
monde
la directive delà des ges selon laquelle
le port du masque pour les soignants
n'est pas de les recommander qu'en cas
de co vide avérés ou suspectés n'at-elle
pas favorisé la propagation du jeu et
dans les établissements
la dgs at elle fait évoluer cette
directive depuis quand quelle est elle à
ce jour la directive elle est la même
depuis le début vous savez que les
personnels de santé se protège depuis
des années en milieu de soins en milieu
hospitalier avec des masques
chirurgicaux selon les situations
notamment de transmission gouttelettes
avaient des masques ffp2 quand il est à
haut risque un acte invasif ou une
pathologie transmise par voie aérienne
c'est le cas de la tuberculose
et puis on insiste depuis des années
aussi pour le port du masque chez les
malades
que ce soit à l'hôpital et en vide et
vous savez que notamment que les
campagnes d'information sur la grippe
ont régulièrement rappelé l'importance
du port de masques pour les malades donc
c'est la pratique que nous avions depuis
plusieurs années sur cette épidémie
le coc vide nous avons beaucoup insisté
pour que les soignants se protéger c'est
pourquoi nous avons fait des efforts
considérables pour réserver les masques
soignants aux soignants et pour les
ehpad le
istres a insisté soit cette priorité
donnée aux ehpad pour que les personnels
qui travaillent en ehpad puissent se
protéger puisse protéger les résidents
par le confinement de l'ehpad par le
confinement en chambre de tous résidents
et puis surtout par la mise à
disposition de ces mesures barrières de
ces masques qui peuvent servir lorsque
l'on pense être porteurs du virus
lorsque l'on aime allah a pâti de la
porte du test rapide en ehpad que ce
soit un personnel qui pense est malade
que ce soit un résident qui a des
symptômes pour que nous ayons en
permanence un lien entre un
établissement de ce type est un milieu
hospitalier entre un établissement de ce
type est un laboratoire et pour que
l'accès aux tests se fasse dans les
meilleures conditions
est il possible de connaître le nombre
de personnes de plus de 65 ans ou plus
largement de personnes âgées décider du
coup vide à domicile ce chiffre peut-il
être obtenus en déduisant les décès à
l'hôpital des plus de 65 ans et les
desserts n'est pas nombre total de décès
recensés par l'insee
dans ce cas est il possible d'avoir ce
chiffre depuis le 1er mars
alors je pense qu'il faut que je que
j'explique comment fonctionne le recueil
de mortalité en france tout décès
survenus en france est signalé à l'état
civil et en mairie que ce décès et lieu
à domicile donc en ville en
établissement en institution ou en
milieu hospitalier
toutes les déclarations de décès
reviennent vers la mairie vers l'état
civil et son eau canalisée par l'insee
et par santé publique france donc on va
avoir une addition des décès
hospitaliers des décès survenus en
institution et des décès déclaré lors de
décès en ville à domicile et tous ces
décès sont réfléter sont analysées par
les chiffres que je vous donne
régulièrement et notamment par cet excès
de mortalité signalé par l'insee au
niveau national depuis la semaine 12 et
qui progresse en semaine 13 1 semaine 14
au niveau régional avec dix régions je
voulais te dire ce que 14 qui ont un
excès de mortalité constatée cet excès
il correspond bien à la somme des décès
hospitaliers des dessins institutions et
des décès survenus à domicile et donc
tous ces décès font l'objet d'une
déclaration individuelle
et l'insee et santé publique france
pourront lorsqu'ils auront accès à
toutes ces données parce que c'est vous
imaginez que ce sont des données très
grand nombre expliqué quel est cet excès
de mortalité chez qui il est survenu
puis c'est plutôt des hommes que des
femmes quel âge à la personne qui est
décédée et de quoi elle est décédée
puisqu'il ya une partie qui est réservé
aux médecins qui est une partie
d'informations confidentielles qui est
analysé aussi et donc nous aurons dans
les prochaines semaines un début
d'analysé de ces causes de décès pour
pouvoir mieux interpréter
parmi cet excès de mortalité quelle est
la part qui est imputable au co vis
desquels un parent qui est imputable à
des causes extérieures à d'autres causes
que le covin une question pour vl médias
une étude menée par les universités de
louvain et d'eindhoven démontre que la
portée des molécules expulsés en cas de
toux ou d'éternuement est plus grande
lors d'un footing la dgs recommande t
elle d'augmenter la distance entre les
joggeurs le port obligatoire d'un masque
alternatif pour limiter les risques lors
d'un footing et il à l'étude alors la
dgs recommande systématiquement de
respecter les distances physiques
je suis frappé encore de voir les gens
ne respectent pas ces distances c'est
vraiment important
on a noté que dans les transmissions
gouttelettes lorsque l'on éternue
lorsque l'on tousse effectivement il
faut être très attentif à respecter les
les gestes barrières bien éternuer dans
son coude dans un mouchoir et ne pas
éternuer en plein air puisque là c'est
là que l'on crée un risque d'aérosols et
donc il faut effectivement que toutes
les personnes qui sortent c'est même pas
uniquement les joggeurs et que toutes
les personnes qu'il sorte et des sons
parfois nombreuses quand elles sont dans
un dans une file d'attenté quand elles
sont devant un magasin quand elles sont
devant une institution qu'elle soit
vraiment très attentive à cette distance
quand on compare parfois les pays
européens avec les pays asiatiques on
voit qu'on n'a pas exactement la même
discipline il faut vraiment qu'on soit
très attentifs à l'essai cette distance
entre nous que ce soit dehors que ce
soit lors d'une activité physique mais
aussi au travail puisqu'on voit encore
des gens qui n'ont pas complètement ce
réflexe parce qu'ils travaillent et tant
mieux parce qu'ils sont utiles mais
vraiment voilà être attentif en
permanence et se dire est ce que je
respecte vraiment cette distance
minimale d'un mètre une question pour
rtl
en mars la mortalité à domicile toutes
causes confondues a bondi en france par
rapport à mars 2010neuf l'insee recense
des pics à +40 4% pour l'île de france
et + 32 % pour la région grand est
avez vous une estimation de quelle est
la part de cdc à domicile duo
coronavirus alors ce ne sont pas les
laisser à domicile c'est là qu'il ya une
erreur et d'essai qui sûr qu'ils sont
déclarés à l'état civil sont tous les
décès tout revient à l'état civil quand
quand vous décédé à l'hôpital ou quand
vous décédez en institution quand vous
décidez à la maison ça arrive forcément
à la mairie et donc c'est là que l'état
civil recense l'ensemble des décès qui
lui sont adressées et donc les chiffres
que l'on donne les chiffres de l'insee
sont bien des mortalité toutes causes et
tous lieux confondus
il n'y a qu'un seul total national cette
augmentation elle est réelle je les cite
elles mêmes 13,1 très importante en
semaine 14 au niveau national il y a dix
régions qui sont un excellent il ya
quarante départements qui sont d'un
excellent set qui le sont avec un accès
exceptionnel j'ai citées ces
départements les départements notamment
franciliens et donc on aura
effectivement un jour la part des décès
survenus à l'hôpital que je donne les
ceux survenus en institution et puis le
delta qui correspond finalement au décès
en ville à domicile deux questions pour
diaspora news magazine qu'en est il des
essais thérapeutiques du kaletra dans le
traitement du coït 19 produits
initialement prescrit pour le traitement
du vih alors c'est effectivement une
démonstration que l'ensemble des
molécules que l'on suspecte d'une
activité au moins une vie trop sur le
court aux navires us sont testés il ya
de très nombreux essais en france à
l'international et évidemment sur les
antiviraux comme sur les anti
rétroviraux puisque le kaletra que vous
citez est une molécule anti rétroviral
utilisé en traitement du vih pour
l'instant aucun essai thérapeutique en
france ou dans le monde n'a démontré une
efficacité confirmé d'une molécule nous
l'attendons évidemment avec impatience
qu'il y ait une bonne nouvelle un jour
sur les essais thérapeutiques mais il
faut aussi dire la vérité
aujourd'hui aucune molécule de le
démontrer son efficacité dans la prise
en charge
des patients infectés par le courant des
virus on avance vers le déconfinement et
idéalement les populations devraient
porter le masque pendant plusieurs
semaines quels en seront les modalités
dans ce contexte l'état envisage t-il
une mise à disposition gratuite alors
savait que l'heure n'est pas en
déconfinement c'est même peut-être
encore plus au respect strict du
confinement des mesures barrières des
gestes de distanciation physique et
social c'est vraiment le message que je
souhaite faire passer ce soit et donc
nous avons bien le temps de réfléchir
aux modalités optimale de déconfinement
puisque aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
d'actualité et pour la raison que je
vous ai cités qui est que la pression
hospitalière reste très importante
j'ai même dit que encore ce soir il y
avait un peu plus de malades en milieu
hospitalier il commence à y avoir de
plus en plus de malades qui n'ont pas le
coc vide mais qui ont subi les
conséquences de ce déconfite de ce
confinement prolongé du fait qu'ils
n'ont pas osé aller voir leur médecin et
donc je le redis ce soit les personnes
qui ont besoin d'un suivi des personnes
qui sont atteintes de pathologies
chroniques doivent appeler leur médecin
et si elles ont rendez vous en milieu
hospitalier dans le service qui les suit
elles doivent y aller pour éviter
d'avoir une aggravation de leur état
plusieurs questions pour france inter le
conseil scientifique repris par votre
prédécesseur william dab plaide pour que
les personnes contagieuses
une fois sorti de l'hôpital soit mis à
l' isolement pour ne pas contaminer
d'autres
on imagine en particulier accueillir
dans les hôtels est ce une stratégie
envisagée aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui s'y
opposent puisque les places sont
vacantes et qu'on a proposé d'accueillir
les sdf dans ses hôtels alors c'est
probablement une confusion là aussi dans
le dans le la notion de contagiosité en
sortie d'hôpital pourquoi je dis ça
parce que d'abord nous avons vous savez
au début de l'épidémie surveiller de
très près les patients qui étaient
hospitalisés en france
il bénéficiait d'une charge virale
régulière et donc on a bien démontré
et ça c'est important de le dire que les
personnes qui n'ont plus de symptômes
non plus d'excrétion virale non plus et
donc leur charge virale notamment dans
l'est dans les sécrétions respiratoires
sont négatives ah c'est un point
important parce qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne sort avec 40 de fièvre et en toussant
de l'hôpital c'est un message important
donc sur la partie hospitalière il n'y a
pas d'inquiétude à avoir sur la
comptabilité contagiosité de quelqu'un
qui a passé huit jours en réanimation
plus vite jouée
en réadaptation et qui rentrent
éventuellement chez lui par contre je
pense que william dab parlait de l'
isolement des patients des personnes
pardon maladies contagieuses en ville et
là c'est encore plus compliqué d'abord
parce que ça voudrait dire qu'un père de
famille ou une mère de famille une
personne qui vit avec des personnes
fragiles
soto isolerait hors du domicile ce qui
en soi n'est pas simple en terme
d'organisation mais surtout cela
voudrait dire qu'il n'a pas été
contagieux dans les heures précédentes
alors qu'on sait aujourd'hui que avant
de consulter avant d'avoir un test qu'il
est très possible de contaminer des
personnes puisque on a 7 partie 2 de
contagiosité décrite porte par les
formes peu symptomatique ou par des
personnes avant l'apparition des
symptômes
donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur ce
type de démarche évidemment si on devait
ouvrir l'accès à des personnes
montagneuse dans des conditions
particulières on le ferait mais c'est
pas aujourd'hui un besoin particulier ou
à orner le pont aérien entre la chine et
la france pour les masques à ce jour
combien précisément de masques sur le
meilleur commandées ont été réceptionnés
alors vous l'avez rappelé les autorités
françaises ont commandé des quantités
très importantes de masse pour répondre
aux besoins très importants des
professionnels de santé pour s'assurer
que professionnels de santé dispose de
l'ensemble des moyens de protection
nécessaires en particulier les masques
chirurgicaux et les masques p2
lorsqu'ils sont indiqués et donc ce
point aérien est évidemment fondamental
nous le suivons de très près nous avons
déjà plus de 35 millions de masques qui
ont été réceptionnées sur le territoire
national l'islande montre qu'en
connaissant la prévalence de l'épidémie
on lutte mieux hormis celles déjà
mentionné dans l'oise et le grand test
une enquête de prévalence à plus large
échelle échelle pardon est elle
envisagée par questionnaire
éventuellement alors je pense que
l'islande travaille surtout sur
l'incidence plus que ce soit le la
détection rapide de tous les nouveaux
cas ce que nous étions évidemment aussi
de faire les enquêtes de prévalence ont
débuté dans de très nombreux dans notre
nombreuses populations il ya des
enquêtes sur les prélèvements sanguins
il peut y avoir aussi des enquêtes de
type insee tout est possible pour avoir
une idée de la diffusion du virus à la
fois par les personnes qui disent avoir
été malade par les personnes qui sont
passés par l'hôpital par des personnes
qui ont développé des anticorps ou
départ les personnes qui rapportent
avoir eu des antiques des des symptômes
et donc être probablement immunisé
contre la maladie ça donne une idée
effectivement de la circulation du virus
dans différentes catégories de
population ou au sein de différentes
régions
plusieurs questions pour mehdi site
selon une estimation extrapolation du
syndicat de médecins généralistes mg
france 1,6 millions de français
pourraient avoir été contaminées par le
col vide le ministère de la santé
sera-t-il bientôt en mesure de fournir
des chiffres évaluant extrapolant le
nombre total de cas et décès ou
faudra-t-il comme pour la grippe
saisonnière encore patienter des
semaines voire des mois pour voir des
données complètes
non nous avons déjà des estimations
quand vous regardez le point
épidémiologique de santé publique france
il y à des extrapolations du nombre de
cas il y aura aussi par les enquête de
séroprévalence une confirmation de la
part de la population qui a été exposée
au virus et donc qui est maintenant
immunisée ça ce sont des chiffres nous
disposerons rapidement enfin sur les
décès nous les donnons très
régulièrement nous avons déjà une
estimation très précise de l'impact de
cette épidémie meurtrière sur la
mortalité en france qu'elles soient
nationales régionales départementales
hospitalière en institution ou en ville
puisque la mortalité totale rapportés
par l'insee par l'état civil correspond
à l'addition des décès hospitaliers des
desserts en institution et des décès
survenus à domicile l'essai clinique
européen discovery qui a débuté le 22
mars et qui vise à tester notamment lé
hydroxy chloroquine dérivé de la
chloroquine devait fournir deux premiers
résultats quinze jours après son
démarrage cette date de résultats a été
décalé vraisemblablement à fin avril
quand peut-on espérer deux premières
conclusions vraisemblablement fin avril
comme vous l'avez dit mais pas pour des
raisons de décalage particulier jeu j'ai
déjà expliqué comment ça fonctionnait on
a inclus des patients
on peut pas donner le résultat du
premier patient ça n'a pas de sens il
faut qu'on ait quand même
jean dizaine ou plutôt une bonne
centaine de patients pour commencer la
conclure qu'en cessant patients au moins
sont arrivés au bout de quinze jours de
traitement on regarde l'évolution de ces
100 patients et on propose les résultats
à un comité d'experts qui va juger si
oui ou non on observe un impact de des
traitements proposés sur l'évolution du
pdu vie des patients si l'impact est
très mauvais on peut arrêter un bras
c'est déjà arrivé
c'est pas le cas de discovery mais ça
pourrait arriver si un traitement était
délétère étaient négatifs était
dangereux pour les patients inversement
on peut ne rien observer c'est tout à
fait possible au cours d'une d'un bilan
intermédiaire et puis si par chance on a
un résultat favorable évidemment il sera
immédiatement rendus publics et on
favorisera le traitement la molécule qui
sera considérée comme bénéfique pour les
patients une question pour la paix m
à combien de décès supplémentaires
correspondent les excès de mortalité
observée depuis la mi mars en france at
on une idée de la part attribuable aux
coronavirus voilà vous savez qu'en
france les données de mortalité sont
donnés très régulièrement par l'insee
elles sont accessibles à l'ensemble de
la population ce sont deux données
publiques
on peut retrouver toute la mortalité
année après année mois après mois et
région par région on peut même regarder
même la mortalité par département en
général le mois de mars fluctuent
beaucoup pour des raisons effectivement
aussi d'épidémie grippale est donc si
vous prenez les dix dernières années la
mortalité en mars oscille entre 38000 et
50 mille décès au cours du mois sur le
territoire français donc au mois de mars
nous nous sommes retrouvés avec un mois
de mars qui sur qui succédait à un hiver
relativement calme il n'y a pas eu de
d'épidémie importante de grippe et donc
la mortalité était normal
lors des deux premières semaines de mars
elle est devenue en excès anormal en
semaine 12 puis avec un excès de plus en
plus important en semaine 13 et
finalement semaine 14 ans nous sommes
maintenant en termes d'observation il ya
un excès nationale le + 40 % sur cette
semaine 14
il ya un excès régionales dans dix
régions il ya un excès de départementale
donc certains départements en excès
important et donc on peut considérer
sur un mois où il ya peu près 40 minutes
45 mille décès chaque semaine ses dix
mille décès qui sont observés en france
donc l'excès de mentalité peut être
calculée sur ceux sur cette mortalité
moyenne par semaine en france
une question pour hospimedia quelle est
la situation actuellement dans les
maisons d'accueil spécialisées et les
foyers d'accueil médicalisés
alors c'est ce que nous observons aussi
c'est pourquoi nous observons tout les
tous les foyers de maladie et tous les
décès survenus dans l'ensemble des
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
il n'y a pas que les ai pas guider tous
les établissements et nous sommes très
attentifs proviendra leur donner l'accès
aux moyens de protection diamants alors
donné l'accès aux tests pour pouvoir
effectivement rapidement tester soit le
personnel soit les résidents
et puis ne savent nous observons
effectivement la situation
épidémiologique et les éventuels décès
au sein de ces institutions
une question pour rfi à la suite de la
publication de l'avis du conseil
scientifique sur la question de
l'outre-mer est ce qu'une stratégie est
en train d'être mises en place et prend
en compte les recommandations du conseil
en particulier pour mayotte
oui nous suivons de très près les
recommandations du conseil mais aussi
les demandes des autorités locales des
préfets des agences régionales de santé
qui connaissent parfaitement leur
territoire il ya des spécificités que
vous connaissez aussi outre mer parfois
l'isolément parfois des zones et des
réponses sanitaire inférieure à celle
que l'on observe en métropole il ya un
exemple très concret que les français
peuvent connaître
il est facile d'évacuer un patient par
route ou par train en métropole c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué outre
mer et donc nous sommes attentifs à ses
particularités a ses spécificités
ultramarines et nous renforçons
considérablement les moyens sanitaires
de tous ces territoires
plusieurs questions pour bfm tv sur les
masques où en est on des livraisons de
masques concernant les commandes
réceptionné de l'étranger quel est le
dispositif de vérification des normes et
quelle est la proportion de masques qui
n'étaient pas aux normes et ont été
refusées alors c'est les chiffres que je
vous ai donné tout à l'heure donc nous
avons ce pont aérien d'importation de
masques qui est évidemment important et
qui se passe bien donc les autorités
chinoises collaborent parfaitement que
l'autorité française il n'y a pas de
souci de qualité
la qualité est surveillé évidemment pas
les autorités chinoises aussi paris
stock
nous n'avons pas observé de défaut et
nous avons déjà eu 35 millions de
masques reçues sur le territoire
j'ajoute à ces masses que toute la
production nationale parce que vous
savez que plusieurs usines françaises
tournent à plein régime pour produire
aussi des masques chirurgicaux et ffp2
et donc nous avons par ses importations
et par cette production nationale
désormais de plus en plus de masques à
fournir à nos personnels soignants une
question sur le rem daisy vire quel est
l'état de l'approvisionnement pour les
essais cliniques mangent-ils des
médicaments non parce que nous sommes
dans le cadre d'un essai clinique donc
il ya un engagement du laboratoire qui
fournit cette molécule à ce que cette
molécule soit fourni à tous les patients
qui sont inclus donc à ce jour il n'y a
pas de difficultés sur cette molécule
dans le cadre d'un essai thérapeutique
c'était les dernières questions genre
merci merci beaucoup